Let's work on forming the /ð/ sound.
Keep your mouth slightly open.
Spread the blade of your tongue and place it in between your top and bottom teeth.
Release the voice over the tongue and through your teeth.
Touch your hand to your throat,...
...make sure you feel a vibration.
/ð/, /ð/, /ð/.
Here's /ð/ in the beginning of some words.
Than, Them, Thy.
And here it is in the middle.
Mother, Whether, Although.
And here it is at the end of some words.
Teethe, Seethe, Breathe.
Listen to these pairs of words to hear the contrasting sounds.
Then, Zen.
There, Dare.
Worthy, Wordy.
Soothe, Sues.
Here are some sentences that use the /ð/ sound.
This clothing is from your mother.
Bathing seems to soothe them.
/ð/, /ð/, /ð/.
Great job!